China gets a bit of a bad rap for
censorship of the Internet and banning
Facebook and Twitter
but now a Chinese company Tencent has
built a social media platform that's the
envy of Silicon Valley
it's called WeChat way Chien and it's
the number one messaging app in China so
why are American tech companies from
jealous of WeChat or maybe even copying
them a little bit it's because we chat
is very sticky sticky sticky you know
look meaning users like me never have to
leave the app to hail a cab or transfer
money or order food so imaginative
tinder and PayPal Apple pay Groupon
Yelp Facebook Amazon and Hoover were all
rolled into one app that would be WeChat
payment is kind of key because that's
how you keep people inside the app right
that you're turning your social network
into a platform for other services so
sort of the WeChat experience may
actually be coming to the u.s. pretty
soon Mark Zuckerberg announced his
vision for a facebook Messenger it
sounded a lot like what you can already
do on WeChat we think that you should
just be able to message a business in
the same way you'd message a friend take
1-800 flowers you don't have to install
a new app or into your credit card again
you just send a message so as we all get
used to doing everything on our phones
anyway Facebook in other Silicon Valley
companies are going to be doing their
best to make their app the stickiest the
one that we go to and WeChat has shown
that it's possible